winter is coming and the players take
their positions the wars to come season
5 first episode this is a good start
it's not quite the hit the ground
running start that we got at the start
of the last season which was a stellar
opening it's a little bit more in line
with all we seen for most episodes for
the start of any given season which is
much more sort of re-establishing where
the players are who they are what
they're after but there's not a ton of
immediate okay this is where things are
going we get little hints of where
certain characters are going to be
headed but there is a clear major path
for anybody to be taking which I mean
first episode that's fine i just kind of
hope that it picks up a bit more in the
next episode I don't want a repeat of
season three words took about three
episodes before anything really felt
like it stirred was happening at all but
the show opens with his first-ever
flashback which I got it gives me a
little bit of a mixed feeling on the one
hand I kind of like that we've never had
flashbacks up to this point I like the
characters I actually have to tell their
own story you don't just cut to it think
of Jaime Lannister telling the story of
him killing the Mad King imagine if that
had been a five facking you'd seen it
but him having to her account that we
just showed you so much of his inner
torment of his character I like that
that's been the way it's gone rather
than actual flashback except at this
point that said the flashback we saw is
probably not something that the
character involved ever would have said
to anybody so there's that King's
Landing right now is primarily taken up
in the funeral of Tywin Lannister which
I was kind of an odd place to start
because one of the early scenes is
there's a dead body there's seriously
there's Jamie we've been here before and
it didn't go well last time but as I
kind of my one major complaint of last
season there is no hint of anything
regarding what happened it's a weird to
have that scene mirrored but in no way
intended to be calling back to it it's
strange seriously I was starting to
think oh this might be interesting to
see where she's going for about
a half second because she was full of
anger and hatred and it really it's
starting to look like she's running out
of things to lose and her in that
position I think could be really
interesting unfortunately the scenes we
saw with her after that she's right back
to the wine goblet our hand and she's
the angry drunk that I've kind of been
complaining about for the last couple
seasons Tyrion and Varys now here's a
pairing that i really like tyrion right
now understandably is in a bit of a funk
but having him paired with Vera's with
his very dry eyes sort of sarcastic wit
it's a really good pairing and it helps
pull a little life out of Tyrion you
know I like where it sort of indicates
where they're going to be headed I'll be
really interested to see how that plays
out now de naris I she's still doing
stuff that I said I like before but I
don't like that she's kind of spinning
her wheels on that a little bit she is
dealing with being a ruler I like that
I've said before that I like that but
what I don't like is she seems to have
settled in it doesn't feel like there's
any momentum any more for her to be
headed towards Westeros and go after the
Iron Throne now hopefully we'll get that
picked up again but it seems like she's
much more concerned in where she is
rather than where she's going which I
mean is the sign of a good ruler I mean
she shouldn't be over extending herself
when she doesn't have a grasp on the
place she's already conquered but for me
as an audience member having been
waiting forever for her and dragons to
show up on Westeros not seeing momentum
in that direction a little bit annoying
up at the wall we're dealing with the
fallout in the resolution from the big
siege of the wall that Mance Rayder the
wildly tried and failed at and Stannis
Baratheon is kind of taking things over
a little bit and Stannis is working for
me better as a character right now he he
seems to have a really firm grasp of
what it is he wants and how to get it
and he just feels a bit more regal in
this episode then then he has in a while
and I'm kind of liking that lady
Melisandre continues to be interesting
I've really turned around on her she's a
character that intrigues me a lot since
it is really taking your cues very
strongly from little finger at this
point and it's interesting and I like
how much she's kind of
been taking her in and I'm I'm kind of
hoping the fact that he's appears to be
trusting her as much as he is I want
that to bite him in the ass later on i'm
not calling that that's necessarily
what's gonna happen but i really kind of
want it to i'm completely random okay i
just say it's a little bit weird how
casually there's a bit of female frontal
nudity in this episode but how far the
show goes out of its way to avoid
frontal nudity on the three naked male
characters that are shown it's a little
weird okay i'm not saying like I
personally need to see dicks flopping
about but I mean the disparity is a
little bit glaring this time around
we're getting some hints at some
interesting new players as well there's
something going on with some it seems
like some kind of resistance movement
going on in murine against an eris and
we get our first look at one of the
sparrows in the form of a reintroduce
character who's virtually unrecognizable
from when we saw him before it's a darn
good thing that he was included in the
previously on game of thrones but at the
front end otherwise I never would have
caught who he was but it that
transformation is actually really
interesting and really intriguing i'll
be curious to see what sort of going on
there he's in King's Landing so we've
got new players new elements on a couple
of places that I'm interested to see
I've been nitpicking this episode a
little bit it's a good episode it's a
good solid start I guess because of how
much momentum season four had really
from the beginning and carried through
straight to the end guess I ain't kind
of hoped that season five would keep
running with that momentum but in an odd
way this episode almost has the sort of
let's cool down a slow down feel that we
usually see as the season finale for a
season so it almost feels more like the
season finale to season 4 than it does
the start of season 5 it's still good
and I'm definitely liking the things
that are getting set up I'm just hoping
that pace gets picked up a little bit
more next time around now I won't say
who cuz im doing spoiler free but we
have our first death of the season right
out the gate in the first episode so who
do you think is going to be the next one
to bite the dust whoever you think it is
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned
you